there was some confusion as to exactly
what was bobbing above the Trump crowd
at Virginia Beach Virginia
even those who recognized its physical
components were more than surprised as
to what they were actually seeing
finally even those who had covered this
16 month long kaleidoscopic mix of those
Americans who have only vague and loose
bonds to reality and others who dwell in
a fantasy world made up of equal parts
video game and television horror series
those who had been be numbed by the
public emergence of the dregs of our
society even they were appalled when
they figured out what it was supposed to
be from the Twitter accounts of Emily
Stevenson of Reuters
from the Twitter account of Jenna
Johnson of the Washington Post from the
Twitter account of Ellie Hall of
BuzzFeed a Hillary Clinton mask stuck on
the end of what appears to have been an
adjustable cane in short Clinton's head
on a metaphorical pike as if she had
been beheaded as if this were the French
Revolution and she was the governor of
the Bastille prison as if as Miss
Stephenson pointed out we were living in
Game of Thrones this is mentioned by way
of reminding you if you are a Hillary
Clinton supporter or if you do not want
to see Donald Trump become president or
both take nothing for granted in these
next 13 days take no poll at face value
take no comfort in trajectories take no
break because she has done this well or
he has done that disastrously assume the
worst assume that the ABC tracking poll
giving her a dozen point lead is the
outlier and the LA Times tracking poll
showing them tied is the baseline assume
that whatever you think is a safe margin
to save this country from democracy
suicide in two weeks it is actually too
low too close and too dangerous Hillary
Clinton's head on a pike and in fact not
for the first time from the Twitter feed
of Emily Schultz on August 31st it's in
the foreground the stick just isn't very
long this was a rush job the guy in
Virginia Beach
seems he took his time whoever he is he
planned it out got his materials
assembled it slowly he is the symbol of
the Donald Trump gang of bullies he is
the symbol of what will be recorded as a
political campaign but which for an
alarming number of its participants long
ago cease to be anything but an enabled
venue for violent fantasies and hatred
based on based on the need to hate it
seems specific to Hillary Clinton but if
it had been Bernie Sanders there would
have been another motif and we know what
it would have been if it had been
Michelle Obama there would have been
another motif and we know what that
would have been if it had been Joe Biden
there would have been another motif and
we can't even guess what it would have
been because it doesn't matter it is the
fantasy of normalized violence that is
the motif and that keeps the Trump crowd
together he stands there blaming Hillary
Clinton and the Muslim faith because
Isis has beheaded victims his supporters
show up carrying images depicting
Hillary Clinton beheaded I don't know
what to do about them if he loses this
past Sunday Trump made a truly
horrifying suggestion that he wants to
keep on holding these rallies for the
next eight years just because I suspect
most of those who now enjoy the
long-form version of Orwell's two
minutes hate will evidently unlike Trump
recognize that the election will have
already ended and the rallies will only
address Trump's psychological problems
and needs
even his angriest gang members will
scurry back under the floorboards and
other places where the bullies hide when
their protection disappears and their
cowardice is exposed so if you want to
stop Trump and you feel relieved by
recent news sleep better but do not
sleep longer if you have viewed the
outcome of this election correctly I
think as life or death for the Republic
you must now view the margin of the
election as life or death for the
Republic vote get others to vote vote in
groups look up and carry with you the
various voter intimidation hotline phone
numbers be ready to photograph anybody
who tries to impede you when you go to
vote and one more thing remember Donald
Trump's ceaseless tireless classless
petition of the claim that the election
is quote rigged but remember it in the
context of what one of this year's great
Patriots his art of the deal ghost
writer Tony Schwartz observed about
Trump and projection remember that
Schwartz tweeted most negative things he
says about others are actually
describing him since Trump has endlessly
bleeded this charge that Hillary Clinton
and everybody else are trying to rig the
election since his interests and those
of the Russian hackers and WikiLeaks are
running on parallel tracks if not the
same track go into the last stretch here
assuming the Trump's charge of rigging
is actually an admission of an attempt
to rig the election on his behalf not
against him does that make you
uncomfortable good Trump imperils our
democracy and is now the proverbial
wounded wild animal in the corner from
him incapable of conceiving himself
mistaken or rejecting or failing
anything in these last 13 days anything
is possible and if that still is not
motivation enough to fight this with
every fiber of your being until the last
vote is counted just remember where this
piece began on a pike that's the closure
I'm Keith Olbermann watch this space